où
l'hiver dernier paulette louer un camion
pour déménager des meubles à son chalet
mais le camion glisse tellement sur les
chemins de campagne qu'elle doit
rebrousser chemin molette est convaincu
que les tenues quitte parce qu'à lyon ne
pouvait pas affronter divers en fait ce
genre de véhicule lourd commercial est
exempté de la loi québécoise qui nous
oblige à utiliser des plus divers de
décembre à mars
pourquoi parce que selon le ministère
des transports les plus qui équipe ce
genre de camions sont assez sécuritaire
pour la conduite en hiver mais quoi
qu'en dise le ministère de frais plus
divers pour ce genre de camions ça
existe vous pouvez les identifier
facilement grâce à ce logo
le problème c'est que ce ne sont pas
tous les locateurs de camions qui
utilisent ces pneus plus sécuritaire
morale de l'histoire
si vous déménagez cet hiver et que le
camion qu'on vous offre n'est pas équipé
de revenus divers portant sur l'eau
allez louer votre camion ailleurs en
hiver